indicting Hunter Biden on three gun
charges filed charges against the son of
President Joe Biden three felony gun
charges I didn't have defending Hunter
Biden on my 2023 bingo card but before
you rage unfollow hear me out Biden was
an admitted crack cocaine user when he
purchased a gun in 2018 it's a felony
for an unlawful user of a controlled
substance to purchase a firearm but
here's why I'm defending the president's
son we don't lose our first fourth or
fifth amendment rights or any others
simply for using an illegal substance so
why is the Second Amendment an exception
this isn't to say you should rail a line
before firing your AR just like you
shouldn't drink alcohol or take certain
Pharmaceuticals before using guns but
recent survey data found millions of
Americans also violate this law simply
because they use cannabis the Second
Amendment says the right of the people
to bear arms shall not be infringed and
that includes people who use illicit
substances too